hot breath oh boy here's a winning name
mama bird the comedian here we go
said how would you advise those of us
still
trying to keep our names in comedy what
can we do from home to keep our comedy
fresh
alive and keep the audience remembering
who we are
uh you got to use social media now so
we're where
people are on instagram doing instagram
live
doing uh things like this this kind of
interview
doing podcasts doing um
[Music]
youtube stuff that's what you got to do
because
there's nowhere to get up i mean i'm
doing a virtual comedy club may 7th
it's called the nowhere comedy club and
it's it's
we're going to do it through zoom but
it's set up like a re like a regular
comedy club uh the laugh factory
in hollywood they do a live stream where
you get up and you perform
for no audience but they put it out on
youtube
so it looked you're you're actually at
the club and on stage now the thing
about that is
you'd have to be established enough to
be a factory regular to get to do that
you know so
if you're not at that level if you don't
have a club or something like that then
you got to just do it yourself
boom do it yourself that's what we're
it's what we're doing here
right now that was a big motivator of
this was i did this show for a long time
and was like i don't want to do skype i
want to meet the comics
and i want to have that connection and
then we got quarantined and i was like
all right i guess skype's the new wave
for this
so i've been doing more of these i
haven't really been doing many virtual
open mics and things like that i've
really been focused on like building
this show up more
so till we get back on stage
you